اذا زياره تاريخيه للرئيس الاوكراني
فولودي ميرسي لنسكي الى واشنطن يبدو انها
حققت المطلوبه الدعم الامريكي السخيه
تواصل والصمود ثابت عقب مرور 300 يوما من
الحرب خلال الزياره اعلن الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن حزمه مساعدات عسكريه جديده لكيف
بحوالي مليارات دولار اهم فيها تزويد
اوكرانيا بمنظومه صواريخ باتشيات التي
ستحمي سماء البيت
يغير واقع الحرب التفوق الروسي الحالي
الوحيد في اوكرانيا هو سلاح الصواريخ
المدمره التي من شان تفعيل هذه المنظومه
ان تنهي هذا التوافق او تحدي منه بشكل
كبير على الاقل
نظري
عن حزمه جديده من الدعم الدفاعي حوالي
ملياريه دولار امريكي واقوى عنصر في هذه
الحزمه هو انظمه صواريخ باترون امر من
شانه ان يعزز الدفاع عن الجويه بشكل كبير
هذه خطوه مهمه للغايه لشيء مجال جوي امن
الاوكرانيا وهذه هي الطريقه الوحيده التي
ستمكننا من حرمان الدوله
الرئيس الامريكي حمل نظيره الروسي
فلاديمير بوتن المسؤوليه الكامله عن
استمرار الصراع في اوكرانيا وفاتوره الحرب
القاسيه امر رفضه الكراملين ورده الى
واشنطن التي اتهمها بدخول حرب غير مباشره
ضد روسيا
لوقف هذه الحرب الفظيعه والولايات المتحده
ملتزمه بضمان استمرار الشعب الاوكراني
الشجاع في الدفاع عن بلاده ضد العدوان
الروسي طالما استغرق الامر ذلك
[موسيقى]